bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui met les autres
économistes au chômage
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du chômage et de l'emploi
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches au
sommaire cette semaine vous l'avez dit
on va parler de l'emploi et du chômage
comment limiter les répercussions de la
crise économique liée aux copies de 19
sur le travail
comment on sauver les emplois quelles
solutions pour limiter le chômage ce
sont les questions qui vont nous
intéresser dans cette émission
et pour cela nous serons en deuxième
partie avec yannick l'horty économiste
et auteur de croissance emploi et
développement aux éditions la découverte
mais d'abord olivier un point sur ces
chiffres du jamais vu depuis 1996 en
avril dernier le nombre de chômeurs de
catégorie a inscrits à pôle emploi a
augmenté de 22,6 pour cent ces huit cent
quarante trois mille demandeurs d'emploi
de plus qu'en mars 2020 il y en tout
dans le pays quatre millions cinq cent
soixante quinze mille cinq cents
personnes privées d'emploi interrogé sur
la situation muriel pénicaud la ministre
du travail a estimé début juin que le
taux de chômage en france passerait la
barre des 10% cette année
pour rappel au dernier trimestre de 2010
9 le taux de chômage s'établissait à vis
à 8,1 pour cent
olivier faut-il réellement craindre une
explosion du chômage dans les mois à
venir
alors il faut la crâne mais en plus si
vous voulez on part de beaucoup plus
haut que ce qu'on dit c'est à dire
hausse avec les chiffres du chômage sont
des chiffres politique on le voit on l'a
vu la très récemment ce ne serait ce que
la semaine dernière avec les chiffres
annoncés par le bls américain où on voit
que c'est un chiffre qui est faux on
sait qu'il est faux mais en public quand
même et on sait qu'il est en france très
partielle puisque les chômeurs de
catégorie à ne sont pas les chômeurs les
gens privés d'emploi les gens privés
d'emploi vous pouvez les comptabiliser
plus tôt à 6 millions
6 millions 5,6 millions 6 avant l'impact
qu'ovide et si vous rajoutez le chômage
dit invisible c'est à dire les foyers
bénéficiaires du rsa de la prime
d'activité ceux qui n'ont plus droit
aucun au chômage vous avez un total de
11 millions de personnes en france qui
ne travaillent pas donc si vous voulez
quand madame pénicaud annonce ses
chiffres il faudrait qu'elle les révise
sérieusement pour avoir une idée non pas
du taux de chômage en pur et dur c'est à
dire ceux qui sont inscrits je vous dis
en catégorie a mais l'ensemble des gens
qui ne travaillent pas ou qui
travaillent tellement peu qu'en fait ils
travaillent pas du tout et et là vous
obtenez des chiffres qui sont bien plus
importants alors il est évident qu'avec
le coc vider avec ce qui s'est passé
alors là on va atteindre des taux de
gens sous employés ou au chômage qui
vont être délirant c'est à dire que il
faut bien voir qu'on part d'une
situation où le chiffre réel n'était pas
de 8% et probablement plus proche de 20
22%
donc je veux aller monter probablement à
30 à 30 % de chômage ou entre 30 et 40
mais dans tous les pays ça va être comme
ça
alors après tout la question est de
savoir combien vont reprendre une
activité et en quelle honte quel bele
justement olivier autre chiffre à
présent avec les projections de la
banque de france et un chômage qui
pourrait grimper jusqu'à 11 5 % à l'ami
à 2021
un niveau jeu suite au dessus des
précédents historiques nous avertit l
institution la banque de france qui
estime qu'il faudra attendre 2022 pour
voir le chômage de redescendre à 9,7
pour cent deux ans donc pour que le pays
à se relève de la crise ça pourrait être
plus long olivier selon vous ça pourrait
beaucoup plus longue mais hors plus si
vous voulez les les
chiffres donnés par la banque de france
dia il faut bien qu'elle fasse quelque
chose depuis que maintenant c'est la
banque centrale européenne qui dirige
les choses mais la banque de france
au lieu de faire des statistiques
devrait plutôt mettre ces c
statisticiens et ses économistes au
chômage parce qu'ils ont jamais réussi
une prévision de leur vie donc france
n'a absolument aucun intérêt je vous le
dis c'est c'est à peu près du niveau des
prévisions d des ministres et des
politiques c'est c'est pas des
prévisions s'est pas basée sur quelque
chose de réel c'est simplement des
chiffres pour vous rassurer c'est des
chiffres qui sont là pour politiquement
vous dire ben grâce aux mesures qu'on a
fait eh bien on à diminuer le chômage
comme nous ont sortis pendant pendant
les deux ans passés qu'il diminuer le
chômage et que c'est grâce à eux c'est
faux on le sait on vous maquille les
chiffres on vous en donne des vous donne
des chiffres qui sont partielles tout le
monde le sait mais tout le monde joue le
jeu en faisant croire que on a une
action sur le chômage qui est faux pour
l'instant en tout cas merci à olivier
allez on passe tout de suite à la
deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine pour parler de l'emploi
nous sommes en liaison avec yannick
l'horty économiste et auteur de
croissance emploi et développement aux
éditions la découverte bonjour monsieur
lortie bonjour estelle bienvenue à
danser cash alors on l'a vu en première
partie le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
a bondi conséquences de la crise allié
au collier de 19 la banque de france est
elle trop pessimistes selon vous ou
alors doit-on attendre réellement devine
2022 comme le président l'institution
pour entrevoir une amélioration
je pense que les prévisions de moyen
terme sont extrêmement compliqué
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle s'appuie
essentiellement sur des modèles etc ces
modèles mime face à puis yeux même sur
les comportements passés et on est en
face d'un choc absolument inédit donc
s'appuyer sur les comportements passés
pour faire des prévisions de moyen terme
c'est pas forcément une solution très
efficace
par contre pour ce qui est du court
terme là on s'appuie les prévisionnistes
s'appuie essentiellement sur les
enquêtes auprès des ménages auprès des
entreprises et ses prévisions donc de
court terme sont d'une grande fiabilité
est donc on a on a une vision je pense
assez précise de ce qui est en train de
se passer en tout cas quand on regarde
les évolutions à la depuis le début de
l'année et celle probablement jusqu'en
septembre
au delà c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
prévoir leur en particulier les
prévisions sur le marché du travail
des prévisions d'emploi de chômage sont
très compliqué parce que disons ces
dernières années on a eu beaucoup de
rupture de comportement notamment les
comportements d'inscription des
demandeurs d'emploi à pôle emploi et
donc on a eu beaucoup de mal à savoir si
c'est si ces nouveaux comportements vont
être pérenne dans l'avenir ou si au
contraire ils peuvent ils peuvent eux
mêmes être modifié monsieur leurs tirs
en première partie olivier en
pourparlers à des chiffres du chômage
évoqué à des chiffres politique est ce
que vous êtes aussi de cet avis non je
partage pas du tout cet avis au
contraire moi je pense qu'il ya eu un
effort de transparence indue du
gouvernement et la ministre du travail
donc c'est à publier a décidé de
de publier de commenter les statistique
mensuelle des demandeurs d'emploi de
pôle emploi alors qu'auparavant la
doctrine du gouvernement c'était plutôt
de se limiter de statistiques
trimestrielles et je trouve que c'est
plutôt pertinent effectivement de
revenir aux statistiques mensuelles et
après j'ai l'impression aussi que
l'insee joue parfaitement son rôle avec
des efforts de communication très très
important sur les chiffres du chômage le
taux de chômage au sens du bit et donc
du bureau international du travail qui a
connu une évolution assez atypique
puisque le taux de chômage du premier
trimestre à abc et il a baissé
essentiellement parce que beaucoup de
deux d'anciens chômeurs sont devenus
inactifs ont été découragés dans leur
recherche d'emploi et pendant le
confinement surtout ils ont pas
continuer à rechercher un emploi
donc ils n'ont pas été classées comme
chômeurs au sens du bit et mais comme
inactifs et donc le premier effet de la
crise a été plutôt de baisser le taux de
chômage au sens du bit et mais
d'augmenter par contre de façon
extrêmement impressionnante
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de
catégorie a mais il n'y a pas de doute
que dans un horizon relativement court
on va voir effectivement le taux de
chômage explose et en france oui j'ai
une réaction à ce qu'elle vient
d'expliquer à leurs tirs de réactions je
vous ai dit ces chiffres sont sont des
chiffres politiques sont des chiffres
qui sont on vous donne une vue qui est
là la vue la plus rassurante possible on
le voit en france on voit ailleurs en
europe on le voit aussi aux états unis
je vous dis les le l'inactivité après
vous pouvez appelez ça comme vous voulez
mais l'inactivité est un est bien
supérieur
ao chiffres qu'on annonce qui sont des
chiffres corps si vous voulez qu'ils
sont des chiffres du chômage le plus
restrictif possible quand on prend cette
fameuse catégorie a ou quand on prend le
chiffre du chômage américain qui n'a
jamais été à 3000 6% et qui était bien
supérieur à celui là donc vous avez ça
dans tous les pays si vous prenez
réellement les chiffres d inactivité en
allemagne vous êtes vous étiez avant que
vite vous étiez plutôt à 12 13 % que aux
chiffres annoncés au chiffre officiel et
donc que vous avez ça dans tous les pays
quand vous êtes un un indépendant quand
vous êtes un travailleur hubert quand
vous êtes donc l'ubs et risation de
l'économie qui est là depuis déjà
plusieurs années fait que quand vous
n'avez plus de boulot vous ne pouvez pas
vous inscrire au chômage parce que vous
n'avez pas d'assurance chômage
parce que bien souvent elle est beaucoup
trop cher pour que vous puissiez la
prendre en tant qu'indépendant donc vous
ne la prenez pas donc ça veut dire que
vous n'apparaissez jamais dans les
statistiques
et donc vous avez et ça aux états unis
vous l'avez encore plus qu'en france ce
phénomène
vous avez des gens qui depuis 2008 ont
repris des petits boulots des temps
partiels
un deux ou trois ils servent dans des
restaurants ils sont le soir dit choqué
et c'est ces gens là et bien quand ils
perdent un de leurs deux ou trois
boulots ils peuvent pas s'inscrire au
chômage parce qu'ils n'y ont pas droit
alors messieurs 45 milliards d'euros
vont être mis sur la table pour
préserver l'emploi c'est ce qu'a annoncé
à bruno lemaire chez nos confrères de
rtl
nous allons être amenés à prendre des
mesures originales singulière pour
préserver à tout prix l'empereur
l'emploi en france at il a déclaré
qu'elles peuvent être selon vous
monsieur l'artiste et meuse
or pour limiter la casse elles sont
largement aujourd'hui en discussion
allait qu il y en a déjà un certain
nombre qui ont été prises il faut
effectivement recourir à des mesures
absolument singulière un choc inédit
réponses inédites et le principe ça doit
être bien sûr d'utiliser tous les
instruments à disposition pour réagir
aux chocs massif qui est en face de nous
qui est dans lesquels qu'on est en train
de subir et donc il ya un principe de
proportionalité de la réponse à
l'ampleur du choc choc massif réponse
massive et il faut pas utiliser un seul
instrument mais un grand nombre
d'instruments
donc on a à la fois des plans de relance
au niveau macroéconomique on a également
des plans sectoriels qui ont été
annoncées par le ministre et puis on a
aussi des mesures des changements dans
dans beaucoup de dispositifs des
politiques de l'emploi qui donne
notamment avec le chômage partiel mais
aussi avec le plan de soutien à
l'apprentissage avec de nombreux autres
avec les les garanties de prêts les
aides à la trésorerie enfin il ya un
grand nombre de mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui déployés et puis aussi des
concertations qui sont en cours avec les
partenaires sociaux au ministère du
travail pour déployer de nouvelles
mesures et donc on est dans une
situation dans laquelle il va falloir
être original il va falloir être
remettre en cause ce qu'on peut savoir
des solutions qui on croit marché mais
et mettre en place aussi de des mesures
inédites
alors olivier vous réagirez ans à ta
question âge dans un instant on remarque
une courte pause
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire aujourd'hui
l'emploi mais le chômage avec yannick
l'horty économiste et auteur de
croissance emploi et développement vos
éditions la découverte alors olivier ans
juste avant la pub où on évoquait à les
mesures pour limiter à la casse quels
sont selon vous les bonnes mesures
alors déjà on les connaît pas pour
l'instant les mesures pour limiter de la
casse puisqu'elles sont en discussion et
les chevaux notamment sur les
dispositifs d'activité partielle
l'apprentissage wiki sondés qui sont des
choses qui ne fonctionnent pas ça fait
20 ans qu'on utilise des plans diverses
et variées pour essayer de faire
diminuer le chômage
et ça fait 20 ans que le chômage ne
diminue pas donc pour la bonne et simple
raison que c'est pas l'état qui créent
les postes je vous rappel c'est les
entreprises et pour l'instant on ne fait
rien pour favoriser le le le l'activité
des entreprises au contraire on
s'endette donc concrets de l'impôt futur
qui va tomber encore une fois sur les
pme et sur les entreprises qui sont
censés embaucher alors rien et que leur
tient avant sur ce plan de relance de
l'apprentissage de l'apprentissage que
vous évoquez la semaine dernière un plan
de relance donc de l'apprentissage a été
présenté pour tenter de sauver l'emploi
des jeunes avant de regarder un petit
peu plus en détail ce plan les jeunes ce
sont ceux à qui sont allés plus en
danger aujourd'hui c'est par là qu'il
faut commencer
oui absolument les jeunes sont les plus
concernés les premiers concernés par par
la crise il ya une véritable
préoccupation collective sur le devenir
professionnel des des jeunes surtout
ceux qui rentrent évidemment sur le
marché du travail ou chic ce qu'ils sont
ils sont déjà
alors moi je ne partage pas bien sûr le
point de vue d'olivier de la marche je
pense qu'au contraire aujourd'hui il
faut agir le la nécessité d'agir n'a
sans doute jamais été aussi forte
qu'aujourd'hui et donc les gouvernements
successifs ont bien compris que sur le
marché du travail il
elle est à la fois à soutenir la
création d'emplois par les entreprises
il ya beaucoup de dispositifs qui sont
mises en oeuvre dans cette direction
pour aider les entreprises dans leurs
créations d'emplois notamment des
exonérations de cotisations sociales qui
sont en france l'un des premiers
dispositifs pour l'emploi donc ça c'est
nécessaire mais c'est pas suffisant il
ya aussi des mesures d'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi pour les aider à
trouver un emploi
et puis il ya des mesures pour rendre le
travail le marché du travail plus
efficace plus transparent pour que
l'information circule bien et donc il ya
énormément de le dispositif qui joue un
rôle tout à fait positif sur le marché
du travail
et parmi ces mesures il ya effectivement
faire en sorte que les gars qu'on a
réussi à obtenir en matière de
dévolution de l'apprentissage en france
soit conservé un que et donc il ya eu
des des annonces extrêmement forte du
ministère du travail pour justement
continuer à développer l'apprentissage
dont tous les observateurs disent on se
s'accordent pour dire que
qu'effectivement c'est une bonne
solution de long terme pour faciliter
l'entrée des jeunes sur le marché du
travail
alors messieurs on en vient à cet
ultimatum de la compagnie aérienne
ryanair la compagnie low cost irlandaise
propose à ses salariés des réductions de
salaire de 20% pour leur éviter le
licenciement on en parle avec le tiroir
car ge d'antoine face à ce crs solutions
pour l'emploi à laquelle on n'avait pas
encore pensé heureusement la compagnie
aérienne ryanair a trouvé la solution
bc il
de ses employés pour sauver leur emploi
entre 20 % pour les pilotes et 10% pour
les personnels navigants et tout ça
pendant cinq ans en contrepartie une
baisse du temps de travail de 20 % et si
les salariés n'acceptent pas il y aura
des licenciements
un bon petit chantage à l'emploi des
familles pour une entreprise qui a
réalisé quand même un milliard d'euros
de bénéfices sur son dernier exercice
2019-2020 clos fin mars
la mesure a en tout cas fait réagir
jusqu'au gouvernement
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail a
fustigé ryanair dénoue sent donc une
forme de chantage
sauf que si l'entreprise peut mettre en
place ces mesures c'est justement grâce
à muriel pénicaud et au gouvernement
tout juste président emmanuel macron
avait réformé le code du travail à grand
renfort dans dawn ans mettant en place
les accords de performance collective
des accords guirande à peu près tout
négociable pour un patron au sein de son
entreprise
et lorsque ce sont les emplois qui sont
menacés
la situation est forcément intenable
pour les élus qui doivent les valider
olivier une réaction à cette proposition
ne rien faire je vais d'abord avoir une
réaction par rapport à ce qu'a dit notre
notre invité juste avant parce qu'il
faut quand même le dire les plans de
formation et d'apprentissage alors qu'on
vient de confiner les universités et les
écoles et que à cause de ça les diplômes
des gens qui vont sortir cette année ne
vaudront rien parce qu'ils ne passent
pas d'examen où le moindre concours
excusez moi mais ça me fait plutôt
rigoler voilà maintenant sur ryanair et
sur la la baisse des salaires et
il est évident que ça n'est pas une
bonne solution pour relancer les choses
vous avez une entreprise qui gagne de
l'argent et qui qui en gagner en tout
cas l'année dernière et qui aujourd'hui
va réduire les salaires pour pour
maintenir l'emploi si c'était à la
limite ponctuelles et que c'était
quelque chose qu'ils ne l'étaient que je
dirais purement appliquée de façon
ponctuelle pendant quelques mois à la
limite on pourrait on pourrait accepter
que ça se passe comme ça mais je les
soupçonne de mettre perpétuellement
quelque chose qui devrait être ponctuel
maintenant le vous avez l'opposé de
ryanair c'est à dire air france où on
sait que là c'est une entreprise qui au
final ne gagne jamais d'argent depuis et
ça depuis très longtemps et qui va être
sauvée par les contribuables qui vont
donc payer quand ils vont partir en
vacances en avion deux fois leurs
billets d'avion une fois par l'impôt et
une fois par leur billet d'avion et avec
leur tienne réaction oui bah d'abord je
peux pas laisser dire évidemment que les
les
les diplômes ne valent plus rien ce
serait mettre sous le tapis les les
efforts considérables réalisés par les
universités tous les établissements
d'enseignement de en matière de
continuité pédagogique et donc il ya eu
des efforts existe donc les diplômes
auront une valeur intacte dans leurs
marchés du travail bien sûr
l'autre point bas sur ryanair bien sûr
on est on est habitué du du style de
management hors norme à 2,7 de cette
compagnie qui n'est pas du tout
représentatif du comportement d des
entreprises en général donc les
désaccords de performance collective
sont pas ici en question assez c'est une
réaction de l'entreprise et puis surtout
ce ce type d'accord qui a été
effectivement mises en place par an 2000
il cède par les ordonnances et bien ne
est assez encadrée en fait par exemple
il faut il faut effectivement qu'il ya
un accord donc avec des représentants du
personnel qui sont qui signent l'accord
et puis les les accords par exemple si
six baisses de salaires il y a c'est
possible il peut y avoir aussi une
baisse de la durée du travail
c'est une baisse concertée négocier et
elle ne concerne pas les minimas de
dents dans les dents des entreprises 1
donc on a on a alors par ailleurs il
faut aussi noter que spontanément sans
aucun accord on a eu des baisses de
rémunération assez forte sur marché du
travail en france notamment au travers
de l'asub quasi suppression de beaucoup
d'heures supplémentaires ou d'heures
complémentaires donc de façon spontanée
disons le il ya eu effectivement une
peut dire une dégradation de la qualité
de l'emploi une baisse des rémunérations
par la suppression des heures
supplémentaires donc ça a été un des
moyens d'ajustement spontanée du du
marché du travail
maintenant on est on est on est souvent
attachés bien sûr une certaine sécurité
salariale en échange d'une plus grande
flexibilité de l'emploi ça c'est un
choix collectif et et c'est pour ça que
dit le risque n'est pas partagée dans
l'entreprise c'est le c'est
l'entrepreneur qui prend le risque est
donc qui peut voir son profit très
fortement diminué en cas de 104
conjoncture négative par contre le
salarié lui est en quelque sorte assuré
sur le marché du travail par un salaire
relativement rigide garantie par son
contrat de travail donc ça ça ça reste
ça reste valable dans le dans le
contexte dans lequel nous sommes
c'est pas par cette méthode là de toute
façon qu'on va relancer quoi que ce soit
et la seule la seule chose que je dirais
c'est que malheureusement on est on va
être contraint de toute façon à avoir ce
genre de réaction des entreprises
pourquoi parce queue leu leu leu cet
épisode du coc vide a été géré n'importe
comment par l'état depuis un bon moment
et donc on va le payer
depuis le départ on va payer tous
collectivement l'incapacité et
l'incompétence de nos dirigeants
merci olivier merci beaucoup et yannick
l'horty d'avoir été parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et auteur de croissance
emploi et développement aux éditions la
découverte
olivier c'est l'heure des questions cash
comme chaque semaine olivier delamarche
répond aux questions que vous lui posez
des questions que vous pouvez lui
adresser sur les réseaux sociaux ou en
commentaire des vidéos
alors parmi les questions à qui vous ont
été posées olivier celle de head and
yellow fasquelle quelles conséquences à
l'annulation des dettes souveraines
détenues par la bce est ce souhaitable
cette solution est de plus en plus
évoquée par certains économistes et
hommes politiques
l'annulation des dettes souveraines
détenues par la bce
écouter de toute façon lee semble quand
même peu probable
en tout cas pour des pays au fort même
pour l'ensemble des pays que ce soit
l'italie la grèce l'espagne la france ex
terra il semble peu probable que de
toute façon ces dettes ne soit jamais
remboursés donc vous savez que depuis
très longtemps on aimait une dette pour
en rembourser une autre la précédent
donc qui arrivent à échéance
donc de toutes façons c'est des pneus
sont pas faits pour être remboursé alors
maintenant est-ce qu'il est souhaitable
que la bce les annuler louis c'est un
défaut de paiement ça s'appelle
maintenant est-ce qu'elle annulera que
celle qu'elle détient ou toute la dette
si elle annule toute la dette est bien
évidemment tout ce que vous détenez au
travers d'une assurance vie d'un produit
bancaire et cetera sera annulé aussi et
peut-être que vous trouverez l'idée
moins amusant allez on passe à la
question des ricv quid de la monnaie et
les coop terre pour tous les foyers
français
abbas et le c'est le rêve de tout à
chacun
finalement si c'est que les jeunes et
les kopter olivier à la monétique
optèrent si vous voulez c'est le
principe de bain c'est ce que fait
d'ailleurs un peu c'est ce qu'ils font
un peu aux états unis quand il envoie un
chèque de 1000 euros par an par personne
là pendant qu'on filme en basset s'est
au final c'est de la monnaie hélicoptère
c'est à dire c'est de la monnaie que la
la la banque centrale crée donc il ya
absolument aucune mais évidemment
contrepartie ou quoi que ce soit c'est
de la planche à billets merci olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
votre fidélité
n'oubliez pas de poser toutes vos
questions à olivier delamarche sur les
réseaux sociaux on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine en attendant sachez
que tous nos précédents numéros sont
disponibles sur internet à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran on se
quitte avec votre dernier mot olivier
j'ai bien une idée pour relancer
l'économie
c'est mettre au chômage les politiques